to discuss with the members of the house
at spain's position
on europe today
politically speaking is a very
significant day
since we have the issue of brexit
but it's also important for us to
address
the major issues facing the union
migration the european parliament
voted in favor of the dublin reform
we called upon the council and the
member states
to vote in favor of proposal
to conclude a long-standing debate
on the relocation of refugees
we had the budget proposal parliament is
calling
for greater investment
between 1.1 and 1.3 percent of gmp
do we think we could be adding money
without asking the member states for it
using own resources
that debate is open there's been a
proposal from parliament on reforming
europe
parliament has made a proposal on
investment
for us it's important to defend our
position
from the half european democracy
we are coming to the 40th anniversary
of direct elections the fa agents
the 40th anniversary of the spanish
constitution
the fa news agency has organized an
exhibition
on that on our premises it's very
important for parliament
i'd like to welcome also
mr borrel the spanish foreign minister
who once presided over this
house welcome back
[Applause]
prime minister president of
the government of spain thank you for
joining us let me now give you the floor
vice president of the commission
commissioner
honourable members
it's a true honor for me to be
addressing you all
and provide spain's contribution of its
vision to this exciting debate on the
future of europe i say it's exciting
in full conviction on the basis of my
own experiences
in 1985 when spain's accession treaty to
what was then the european economic
community was signed
i was 13 years old despite all the time
that's gone by
i still remember that day clearly
i recall our feelings amongst those of
us who had
suffered from the lack of democracy and
freedom in my country in spain
for decades i remember how moved a whole
generation of spaniards were
my parents generation men and women for
whom europe
for those many years of dictatorship
meant freedom and the rule of law
progress
and cohesion that point in time as far
as spain was concerned
represented many things above all a
guarantee that there would be no going
back
that at last we would be at peace with
our history
and that at last no one ever again
would ever destroy democracy in our
country
since then subsequent generations of
spaniards
including my own have seen the internal
borders
become mere relics of history and we've
built up
solidarity and affection with peoples
that were once remote to us
always on the basis of respect for the
values that we now
identify as european values legal
certainty respect for the rule of law
dialogue and tolerance feminism and
equal opportunities
fraternity coexistence
an ecological approach and solidarity
between
generations and so i think i'm in a
position to say that i'm
enthusiastically
pro-european and i'm proud to be so
particularly now
when some are wielding anti-europeanism
as a supposed electoral asset thank you
president tayani
for giving me this opportunity to
address the house
placing parliament at the heart of this
debate
seems only right and profiting me
particularly as we're on the point of
celebrating the 40th anniversary of the
first direct election to the european
parliament
the union would make no sense without
the primacy of democratic values
honourable members before going any
further i would like to refer to
yesterday's vote in the house of commons
as you would only expect from the prime
minister of the member state i
respect the the vote of the house of
commons but i cannot help but regret
its rejection of the withdrawal
agreement
reached between the uk and
the eu of the negotiations lasting more
than a year and a half and i'd like to
pay homage
to the maine negotiator mr barnier for
the huge efforts he's made
to keep the 27 member states united
as i was saying that agreement was
negotiated on over a year and a half
and i believe it's the best possible
agreement
it's the option that provides the best
protection
for the needs of the united kingdom and
the whole range of member states and
therefore european society
it's the option that provides the
greatest protection not just of our
citizens rights
but also the rights of the main economic
players
it's an agreement which contains a
bounce of concessions that's very hard
to reach
and which first and foremost seeks to
ensure that there's an orderly
withdrawal
it therefore falls to the british
government
to adopt the decisions it thinks
appropriate regarding
the further steps to be taken we as
member states and
eu institutions will do our job
both administrators and the commission
will adopt the measures we need to
minimize the impact
of any possible no deal brexit
honourable members
i've always expressed my view both in
the spanish parliament
and in a range of interviews
with the media that brexit is a disaster
for the british people and for the whole
union no one's going to win from this
we will all lose particularly the
british and in particular
those who greatest need support from
their government the most vulnerable
but it's a sovereign decision which we
cannot fail to respect
which is why i hope that the united
kingdom will choose to maintain the
closest possible
relations with the whole european union
it's their decision to take
but our principles are clear the
integrity of the single market
the indivisibility of the four freedoms
and the free hand for the union to take
decisions
in the context of those two points we
will always be able to reach an
agreement
honourable members i would like to talk
to you about the need to mobilize europe
i want to talk about the need to provide
some fresh legitimacy for europe in the
face of the new
uh challenges before us
but also yeah these are the the major
players inside and outside europe who
want to destroy europe
as a leader of the social democratic
family i know that people expect me to
talk about
social europe and i will do so because
uh
there'd be no mistake about this social
europe is europe of our convictions
but we need moral conviction
that's why we need to reconcile the idea
of europe with the expectations of our
citizens
so if you ask me what the core idea of
my speech is
it's a much wider appeal to put it in
nutshell
if europe is to protect us at this
historic juncture we need to protect
europe we need to build a europe of
rights that will
respect the most vulnerable
protecting europe means providing
impetus
for a lot of opportunities for our young
people and
long-term unemployment they wouldn't
just generally be
people in their sixties we have people
in spain who are only 45 years old
but are still long-term unemployed
we have to press ahead with uh social
europe that will strengthen our business
and industrial fabric
while safeguarding labor rights
protecting people from precarious
working conditions it also means
we have to guarantee the security and
defense of our citizens
and make sure that europe is a global
player in a position to defend its
values and ideals
protecting europe means reasserting our
commitment to the paris agreement
on climate change it also means
completing economic and manchester union
once and for all this is the only way
that
we will have a europe that can be
reconciled with its citizens europe
which have a free hand to defend
its welfare model and a europe
which can complete the church of
economic
monetary union only with all this will
be able to rise to the challenges
that will affect the
the next decade with adequate guarantees
for opposition
it's no time for hesitation the enemies
of europe
our conviction and determination can
overcome authoritarianism
however uh hardline the rhetoric may be
used by some who try to exclude others
however questionable their methods and
lies
the time has come to show our conviction
and determination
to pursue our union there's a real
battle being
waged now a battle of ideas
there are those who want to to turn
inwards
versus those who are pursuing progress
we know that you can never build
the future by moving backwards
that's why we must was not backpedal on
defending the european model
europe can only protect us
if all of our member states european
institutions
civil society and the whole of society
protect europe to those who are putting
out
these messages
in this chamber as as well that that we
want
to look inwards we have to say europe is
not and never will be a threat
to the extraordinary diversity of our
countries our languages and our cultures
on the contrary europe is a multiplayer
it does not define people's identities
you're not at at all less spanish for
being
european on the country the european
union is not just
an expression of geography it
was is and always will be a community of
values the values of the french
revolution
liberty equality and fraternity which is
so important today
values which are those of open
optimistic societies
innovative creative societies who see
the future as an opportunity never a
threat
societies making necessary link between
economic competitiveness and
the fundamental value of social cohesion
and our welfare model which is part of
our definition is europeans
it's a commitment which supports us
together
behind the sustainable development goals
of gender 2030
a real global social contract from the
coming decade
which has europe as its main
proponent arnold members clearly there
is
a disenchantment in in society against
the mighty drop of globalization
um extremist rhetoric is
compounding this and this the paradox
here on the one hand globalization has
redistributed wealth amongst the regions
of the planet thereby reducing
global inequality but at the same time
it has increased inequality within our
societies
so if you think about it the increase of
anti-european messages
draws out a lot of its origins in this
phenomenon
and yet globalization is not a natural
disaster that we're defenses against
curtis said that parents need to give
their children
roots and wings well in the same way the
european union needs to provide its
citizens with
roots that's to say they have to feel
that they are protected that there's a
solution for them and also
has to give them wings it has to empower
them so that they can take part
in the prosperity of the opportunities
of a globalised world
on members we're facing um
early part making change on the 26th of
may a new political cycle will open in
europe
and baraji has to focus on governing
globalization
to guarantee that the european social
model
remains we need to consolidate the
foundations of economic and monetary
union
and i would like to add to that an
environmental
and political and social union
a decade down the road many of our
fellow citizens are still suffering from
the the consequences of the crisis
there's still social exclusion
precarious conditions and low wages out
there
there's a crisis there that
unfairly led people to associate europe
with austerity
the the austerity of those who always
had to be
austere as opposed to to um
those who were never using authority and
actually caused the financial crisis
there's a
consequence of inequality between
generations
the young people suffering across
continent and gender and equality too
because
women are suffering the impact of
precarious
conditions and labour inequality the
most
and this undermines the welfare state
and it has to recognize that this
cisco's
divided our societies but it divided us
two divided countries of the north
and south east west creditor and debtor
countries
well the time has come to close that
period
and provide fresh legitimacy where it's
most needed amongst our citizens
in pursuit of that we need to call for a
social europe
europe of rights social and territorial
cohesion is an essential
pillar the only one in the world i would
say for for european societies
to restore its legitimacy that you must
promote a new social contract
making globalization a source of
opportunities not just of threats
it's vital to strengthen social cohesion
with
clear goals
for employment social justice and the
sustainability of our welfare state in a
way that can be gauged
we have to strengthen the prospect of
that in european procedures
governing economic coordination and
political cohesion
and this honourable members is
the line of thinking behind our
proposal for a european
unemployment insurance a real backstop
for people
from which which we can use to make a
palpable
reality of concepts of european
solidarity and citizenship
this is a course that we must promote
actively in parallel with the completion
of emu
similarly it's vital to take up the
task that the european trade unions
place in our hands
the directive on reconciling personal
and
working life as well as that on
transparent and predictable working
conditions in the european union
we have to ensure that people regardless
of race sex or age
have access to the labour market the eu
has to be part of the struggle against
precarious
working conditions in certainty at work
means that you will face uncertainty in
your life
we cannot allow the idea that our young
people are doomed
to a worse life than the previous
generation
the spanish government is is therefore
vitally committed to
the youth guarantee remaining honourable
members
seven months ago spain put together
the government with the largest number
of women of any oecd country
this is a paradigm shift on the course
towards real
equality between men and women where
there's still much to be done
this is a course we would never have
managed to to cover had it not been
for the inspiration and example and
impetus of europe
and so here in this house today i want
to express my thanks
to the
female members from right across the
continent for their
commitment and to feminism which has
become very much part of the
community a key
spain is not going to take a single step
backwards in the cause of gender
equality
we need to press ahead but we need the
whole of europe on board
and that's why today i wish to propose
the adoption
of a binding european gender equality
strategy
to fight the the gender gap the higher
unemployment rate amongst women
and the higher level of precarious
working conditions suffered by women
predominantly
europe's voice must lead this struggle
in what is the
the century of women honourable members
we need
to move forward in making
the principles of the european pillar of
social rights compulsory equal
opportunities access to the labour
market in decent
fair working conditions and
social protection inclusion i therefore
reiterate my support
for the european labor authority to
oversee workers rights in the labour
market
europe must extend equal opportunities
and guarantee it
then access to studies including
specialization courses in culture
science and research
i'm sure we will all agree that we have
a vital bastion
against those who want to destroy
the european ideals honourable members
in order to
ensure the security of our citizens
and strengthen our role as a true global
player we need to act decisively
and determinedly in europe of security
defence
slightly more than a year ago we set up
the permanent standing cooperation
we're taking the first steps towards
ensuring we have our own defense
capacity
after decades of paralysis and the time
has now come to be decisive in pursuit
of this
we need to move ahead openly towards the
creation of a true european army
the union of honourable members must
show the world
that it has chosen to be a soft power if
i could put it that way
it's a deliberate choice it's it's not a
reflection of weakness
we need the capacity to project
beyond our borders and the political
willpower to do so there's a vital
pre-recognition
to be a credible global player europe
union is an attractive model from for
many parts of the world
it's our union which allows us to aspire
to playing a role of
global leadership we represent the
possibilities of a multinational
order
based on the law
and accepted common rules
spain is prepared to play its role in
assuming that leadership
thanks to our privileged relationship
with latin america north africa and the
middle east
nonetheless given major
global challenges before us europe has
far less
clout than it has in in other areas
where the union holds an exclusive
competence
and with that in mind i'd like to share
some thoughts with you we need to become
a true
global actor which we're not today
that's why we need to do away with the
rule of unanimity not just in
external policy but also taxation
the mff and the verification mechanism
regarding the rule of law and human
rights
protecting europe means today more than
ever
equipping it with the tools it needs and
they have to be flexible as it takes
decisions
we have to commit ourselves to a new
type of sovereignty
nothing more or less important than
european
sovereignty thirdly honourable members
we must complete the
design of the single currency and move
ahead
in the multi-annual financial framework
50 years ago at the hague
the heads of state and government at the
time
created
the course of action that would take the
european economic community
towards economic and manchester union
paradoxically
the final year of every decade since was
marked by substantial progress
in this field 1969 the the the hague
summit 1979
the european monetary system 1989 the
law plan
to move towards economic monitoring in
1999 the official launch
of the euro but between that
uh yeah and now
there's just one eloquent gap in that
almost perfect sequence 2009
when the international financial crisis
showed the shortcomings in the design of
the euro
nothing provides a better illustration
of the impact of the crisis
than that broken rhythm so let's make
sure that
2019 is a year in which we really do
make progress
the euro is a success story which has
has provided
economic benefits despite all the
problems of the crisis
and it also has provided political
successes for the european project
but without the reforms we we need to
strengthen our single
currency the eu will still be incomplete
and exposed to
instability so it's
it's not just a question of
strengthening financial system by the
banking
union with the three uh mutualized
pillars of the single resolution
mechanism the single supervision
mechanism
and the single deposit guarantee fund
but
rather over the median term we have to
go for closer
fiscal integration with stabilization
tools to
offset the adverse effects of economic
activity
and jobs in future crises giving europe
pressure discipline in this area
is a key concern so our citizens have to
be able
to feel that they have a role in reform
we protect their savings protect them
from inflation and
the economic cycle a single currency is
a key pillar
in a shared political project the reform
of the emu
must ensure that social protection and
inclusion
are part of the way we design our common
economic policies
at this stage when economic conditions
are favorable this is the time
to get ahead of the game
we don't want the same old couplets
setting the agenda for the european
union
we need to re
complete the design of the european
before any future crisis weakens our
currency let's learn from recent
experience
and press ahead decisively we cannot
allow ourselves
to pay the price that we know in action
would entail for the institutions
and above all for those we represent
here and in the other institutions and
in
the the national sphere regarding the
new multi-annual financial framework we
are facing new challenges
but we also need to consolidate
strategic initiatives
such as the common agricultural policy
or the cohesion policies which are so
important
for countries such as spain urban europe
cannot switch off from rural europe if
you allow me to to put it that way
reducing the budget implies the idea
that europe is withdrawing
it's moving backwards so let us also
think
about who would benefit from that kind
of message the commission's
proposal in the view of the spanish
government contains some very positive
uh elements regarding the
the level of expenditure the external
dimension of the monetary policy you'll
come back to that
and strengthening innovation and
technological
development programs europe has to be
sovereign in
innovation reduce its dependency on
in um the area of artificial
intelligence
content um computing security and or
automation only by pooling our
capacities and
resources will will we have the
guarantees we need
we have to double the erasmus program
that's a particularly desirable
uh proposal but we have to press ahead
on in other areas too
we need a european response to phenomena
that we we thought we'd overcome in our
societies
would term
as a result of growing inequality and um
child poverty europe opportunities
has to start in childhood that's why i
would express specific support for the
idea of
a child guarantee to tackle social
exclusion
at the earliest
stage
life childhood honourable members our
proposal even with its shortcomings
is a good starting point but uh we need
to take a great leap forward
uh our union is worth much more than one
percent of gnp
the the money has to be uh spent
prudently
we need the the capacity to address
the priorities that derive from the
uh transnational challenges we face
we all went from having a reasonable
european budget which will generate
synergy and economies of scale
protecting europe means advancing in
social europe of defense
emu a federal europe which will
recover legitimacy if it regains
um favor in its citizen's eyes it has to
tackle the that perceived distance with
measures that will make it a palpable
reality honourable members i i want um
to pick up that idea again
by uh addressing the the last element
of of my speech on climate change and
migration in both areas i want to
appeal to european values we need
consensus
to bring together uh those who drive
we need to be united against those who
get um benefit from
seeing us divided
these are areas where the the
battlefield
is chosen by by those who will never
believe in europe
it's a concept from which they're trying
to undermine
the foundations of liberal democracy and
this is where once again i
appeal to the need to protect europe to
preserve the european model and
and values
on climate change at recent
international forum we've seen
skeptical positions being pushed forward
some being resigned others even
aggressive our perspective
on this is that we have to
bring together a global commitment
on the energy transition we have a
vector for modernizing the european
economy
but at the same time we can pursue
cohesion by
promoting energy interconnections to
improve
efficiency and cut emissions the
consequences of this
challenge can be devastating
neither authoritarianism nor
the kind of nationalism that seeks to
exclude people who deny the evidence
that frontiers are
useless and against this challenge
that's why they are acting from on the
basis of irrational occasionism
climate change can only be fought with a
recent scientific approach
and science and reason are both on our
side the side of a europe which is a
vital
voice while others look inward
similarly let me refer to migration
we're talking about an issue in in which
joint coordinated action
in cooperation with countries of origin
transit and
uh destination are vital as far as spain
is concerned
this is crucial given our position on
the external borders of the union
we are very aware of the key role played
by
countries which are very important for
the holy spirit but certainly for spain
such as the kingdom
of morocco when it comes to cooperation
and
checks i want to
underscore the importance of that
correction here in the house
we need to promote a parallel
global focus on this area the marrakesh
conference was
a first step towards multilateral
management of migration
unfortunately spain is one of the very
few countries who signed up to that um
global agreement
i know how divisive this is who can be
within our societies as you all do
but we cannot start from a a negative
focus
looking solely at illegal or irregular
migration regular uh immigration
legal migration has positive
implications for
the development of economy plays a vital
role
in sectors facing a labor shortage and
helps offset the aging of the population
but there's no possible response
to this challenge unless we have a
commitment towards the continent of
africa
which needs a wide-ranging
socio-economic transformation
this political course over the medium
long term
has to be channeled in parallel with
border checks which is the duty of
states
a single borderless area means a joint
migration policy and the reform of the
um european common asylum systems play a
central role in that we need rules
tailored to reality
two principles will help us in that
reform responsibility and solidarity
amongst the complex negotiations we we
mustn't lose
sight of the original meaning of the
reform to fulfill our
duties which derive from international
conventions of the protection of human
rights
towards people who are fleeing
persecution war and conflict
europe's prestige is caught into
question honourable members when within
our midst
we find attitudes emerging which run
counter
to the very essence of humanity
showing solidarity to others allows us
to show it towards ourselves too europe
with its democratic
key honourable members is the
trendsetter
that's our strengths
we don't follow fashion honourable
members
our division here in the union is our
greatest weak point
the only ones who benefit from that as i
was saying earlier in my speech
are those who are seeking to ensure that
our model
fails and collapses it's a model which
is unique in the world and criticizes a
virtuous triangle of democracy economic
progress
and welfare state overcoming our
divisions means we need to understand
one another better
and fight stereotypes in may we'll be
facing a crucial test
we're facing those who are already
wielding a message on our continent on
the members
it's a message which covered europe in
ashes just a few decades ago
many people then also thought their
uh rhetoric and the dresses
were harmless peace democracy and
freedom
can never be taken for granted i saw
this
myself in the 90s in bosnia when i was
working for the un
in the devastated city of sarajevo the
barbarism that we thought
had been expunged from the history of
our continents
emerged again when no one was expecting
it and it was fed by forces that always
oppose hatred to reason
the upsurge of these forces not only
poses a threat to our project of
integration
it also subtly
applies conditions to the
agenda those who are opposed to them
assuming
today no one in this house
no pro-european person should be
pushed off course by those forces i'm
turning to you to ask you
to remain firm
in defending european values
you need strength to to resist the siren
song of authoritarianism
because they only have one goal to
destroy europe
that's why i'm appealing you to protect
europe and its citizens over the coming
years our process of integration
will move forward there will be
divergences of opinion
there will be steps forward and
backwards
consensus of course um will not give
everyone full
satisfaction it's only natural the union
is the synthesis of
distinct ideas sometimes contradictory
ones
ideas which are compared in a peaceful
way
so that we can achieve progress in
welfare and prosperity while preserving
stability in a changing world
we rely on a solid basis
solidarity in practice which has has
grown
over the years you can see it every time
we've suffered a terrorist attack when a
spanish citizen
puts a french flag on his um
social media profile in solidarity when
there's been a terrorist attack in paris
what he's doing is embracing the
european flag when a german citizen
feels the attack on the ramblers in
barcelona something affecting
himself he's also embracing the european
flag
when we honor the victims of the
atrocious terrorist attack just a month
ago in this this very city
what we're all doing is embracing the
european flag
the enemies of europe can do nothing
against this growing
feeling of indivisible rather invisible
but
real solidarity
and it's taken strong root amongst young
people
they're the ones who who wield the
european flag as a symbol against
injustice
or the drip towards authoritarianism
against machismo and racism
or simply to express their unease
against decisions which are logic to run
contrary to the logic of our
age forgetting history is a luxury we
cannot allow ourselves
being conservative
when there's uncertainty makes us more
vulnerable we need to be
determined that's what will allow us to
recover our last impetus
we're facing a form of authoritarianism
which
feeds on an invented nostalgia
but there's no worse nostalgia than for
uh feeling nostalgic for
something that never happened as a great
spanish song says to all those who are
living on this invented nostalgia and us
and this
was peace firm when we were divided by
borders was there economic progress
when the customs limited trade
was there any progress on social and
citizenship rights in each of the
countries
and more than we've had across the union
recently over these years
very close from here the battlefields of
the first world war there you will see
the answer to those questions
that's why i'm saying where people are
trying to turn backwards what we need is
progress
against the rhetoric of those who are
pursuing identities which include others
we need identities that will bring
people together
the the past will never be
the future of our societies including
what
frank zimmerman says the past is a a
place
from which we can learn what we've got
right and what we've got wrong
it's the time to mobilize for europe
it's the moment to protect and defend
our values a single unique project in
the world
this is the only way we can defeat those
who within and
outside europe are trying to destroy our
deals and they want to do so let's not
forget for a single reason
because of the values that we defend
in defending our values we will find our
answer
because we set out on that course
honourable members we need
conviction and determination we need to
bring together our ideals as we uh seek
a pragmatic course just as we have done
now for more than six years this task
as uh those who've been inherited this
great legacy
is to preserve and improve improve
what's been handed down to us so that we
can pass it on to future generations of
europeans
if we've learned one lesson at crucial
points in our
history is that resistance means moving
forward
the generations that you represent in
parliament
you have to embrace the task of
protecting europe so that europe can
protect its citizens
thank you for your kind attention
thank you i am about to close the catch
the eye requests
therefore i would suggest that
if you want this is your absolutely last
opportunity to sign your name on the
list
and now close the list which is
therefore now complete and i would
urge all these speakers on behalf of the
groups to respect
the time limits that have been allocated
to them
as a speaker in this debate please
respect the timing
first of all it is my pleasure to call
friends timor months on behalf of the
european commission
mr president i want to start by thanking
prime minister sanchez for his inspiring
speech
and the one notion i think he tried to
share with us
is that if europe wants to protect its
citizens
we politicians have a collective
responsibility to protect europe
a europe that is united and strong can
actually
protect its citizens and those who
sell the illusion that you can protect
citizens
by um isolating those who are
different by building fences and walls
by selling a pipe dream of nationalism
will only lead to disappointment because
there
is no protection in protectionism
but there is isolation in isolationism
and nations left on their own in europe
would not be able to face the many
challenges
the world is throwing at us only a
united europe
only a united europe can do what its
citizens demand
and that is protect them and help them
shape their futures as
independent people free people
i know that um europe runs deep
in pedro sanchez's veins he's from a
generation
who were the last to be born still under
dictatorship
the generation which went on to grow up
with the hope of freedom and democracy
and then to realize the rights and
freedoms of european membership
as spain took its rightful place at the
heart of
europe the message i would have for the
spanish government today
is looking back also myself
over the last 40 years
i believe it is right to say that europe
shaped spain as it is now
because that was the wish of the spanish
people
but also believe it is right to say now
that spain should step
up and shape europe take its
responsibility as a leading nation in
europe
use the potential you have to shape our
collective future
you are strong resilient you've shown
in this terrible crisis that affected
the spanish population
how you can come out of it stronger yes
unemployment is still at 13 it's much
too high
but you've made huge progress in the
last couple of years
to put that behind you with a
determination of the spanish people that
i think was an inspiration
to all of us in the rest of europe
and also the spanish people share the
analysis that europe is first and
foremost about democracy
liberty freedoms prosperity and that
these things
are precious and can never be taken for
granted
spain has such a unique and important
place in our union
and its european story goes back much
further than 1985.
in particular about how much europe owes
to the determination and the ideas
of people like salvador de madariaga who
helped to build the european project
after the second world war
he never gave up on the idea of a free
spain and a democratic
spain and people who never give up
on their ideals even in the darkest days
are the people who shape
our future best he saw our european
destinies intertwined with the destiny
of spain
our identities linked our successes
linked
this is why he would be proud of what he
sees today a democratic spain
celebrating 40 years of its constitution
now at the heart
of a strong and united union he will be
proud
of the social and economic progress made
since 1985.
whilst growth is now above two percent
unemployment as i said is still too high
at 13 so there's clearly a lot that
needs to be done
but there are so many positive signals
in the economy the economy that's back
on its feet
and i again want to stress that this is
thanks to the courage and determination
of the spanish people and also i have to
add the solidarity
of european people
a solidarity that was more than
reciprocated
by spain it has received the solidarity
from its european partners during the
financial crisis but it has shown
time and again that it will also show
solidarity to europe
and it is showing it on a daily basis if
i look at the issue of migration
countries like spain and malta even in
difficult times really show solidarity
with people in dire need
spain has been a leader in many respects
and you pedro have been a leader in
generously welcoming
those stranded on board of the aquarius
boat this was
for me a defining moment in europe when
you stood up
and said on behalf of the spanish people
we will not let these people
float on the sea and get into trouble
that
is true true political leadership
not the easy way out of looking away not
the easy way out
of blaming refugees but taking the
responsibility
for their destiny and i salute you for
that
the images of these boats and the
divisions caused by only a small number
of arrivals on our shores
show the need for europe to overcome its
differences and find a sustainable
solution that works for all
it is now high time we conclude the
necessary reform
of our common european asylum system
only if we do
all these reforms we can come to a
sustainable situation
only border protection will not get us
there
we also need a working uh asylum system
based on solidarity
and based on the fundamental values of
the european union
i also want to underscore pedro what you
said about
africa if there is
one continent that will be defining for
the future of europe
it is africa there is no one
else in the world that can take this
responsibility or wants to take this
responsibility on their shoulders than
europe
this is our sister continent a stone's
throw
away from our shores and if we do not
work towards a collective responsibility
for the future of both continents
and the troubles of africa cannot be
kept away from europe
however high the fences you want to
build
only stability prosperity optimism
and a future people in africa can
believe in
will create the necessary stability for
europe also to be
stable and prosperous and free in the
future and i call upon you pedro to lead
in
europe to lead europe to understand
that this relationship with africa
should not just be an issue
for mediterranean members of the
european union but for every single
member state
whatever its position in the european
union
there will be in our budget there will
be an almost three-fold increase in
funding for migration and security
to reach nearly 33 billion euro this
will be especially
important i think for spain not only
because you have shown such
responsibility in solidarity as
concerned migrants
but also because you know all too
tragically the horror of terrorist
attacks
on spanish soil funding for research and
innovation will also be increased by 50
percent
and the new digital europe program with
9 billion euro
will support europe's digital
transformation both of these will
provide real opportunities to further
boost
the productivity of the spanish economy
we will build on the success of the
juncker plan
which has already triggered more than
46.2 billion
of investment in spain's economy and
supported almost 150
000 small businesses and it is already
making a difference on the ground
through cleaner more efficient buses in
palma de mallorca
and a new mill for recycling paper in
faragota for example creating 110 jobs
in the local community and supporting
spain's
circular economy in the progress in the
process i know
prime minister your strong your
government's strong attachment
to uh the sdg's sustainable development
goals
and i know spain's needs to make that
transformation as europe
needs to make that transformation and i
want to use
the opportunity to also salute my
colleague
here next to me who's been a leader in
the world
to make sure that europe can really
really
attain the paris uh climate goals i
think
i think he has been one of the global
leaders in this
respect and he deserves he deserves our
recognition
for that the new program
investor u has the potential to go much
further by triggering another 650
billion
euro of investment across europe between
2021
and 2027. and following in the footsteps
of manuel marin
the founder of erasmus exchange program
we will more than double its funding
to more than 30 billion euro i had the
pleasure of working with marine in the
past
if ever an explosive character it was he
but he could get things done
this increase will open up new
opportunities for many more young
spaniards to gain new skills
and experiences all of us in the rest of
europe have had experience with young
spanish people coming to work in our
countries
and we were all inspired by their
knowledge by their determination
by their openness to differences
all of these investments can and will
make a real difference on the ground in
spain and across our union
so it is crucially important that we can
agree on our new budget as swiftly as
possible
i count on the support of pedro his
counterparts and this house
to make it happen i also want to
emphasize the importance of the equality
agenda the spanish government has put
forward
why don't we have a better plan
to put an end to the pay gap in europe
between
men and women why don't we all
agree that we will put an end to the
pension gap
which is still 40 in europe
why don't we all agree to break the
glass ceiling and to make sure that more
women are
on boards why do we put 50 percent of
our human potential on the back burner
in europe
this is unacceptable this is
unacceptable and i count
on pedro's government's leadership to
make this happen
why don't we finally put an end to
violence against women
why not this is our duty
and why don't we call out those who
falsely claim family values as an excuse
to deny women their full rights in
society
these are not family values to say that
women
should not have full rights these are
not family values
if you use them to justify violence in a
marriage
never ever can can there be a
justification for that
honorable members prime minister
in my eyes spain and its european story
are an example for the future of our
union
it shows what the values that we talk
about really mean and it shows how much
can be achieved
when we work together take
responsibility and make european
solidarity
truly meaningful if europe is to protect
then we need to protect europe thank you
very much
[Applause]